welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to pet sematary has just seen
worldwide release and the movie stands
as one of the best Stephen King
adaptations ever put to film the movie
is packed with gruesome moments shocking
twists and an atmosphere that feels like
it was ripped straight out of your worst
nightmare
one of the most unnerving aspects of the
film is the creature that haunts the
titular grounds known simply as the
Wendigo throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the monster and how it
plays into other King works from here on
out its full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen pet sematary yet and you
may want to skip this video for now
without the way I hope you enjoy the
breakdown and let's get into everything
that you need to know about the Wendigo
okay so firstly whilst we never see the
Wendigo in pet cemetery
there is definitely hints towards its
existence ranging from shadows in the
dark its nerve tingling howl the
movement of the overgrowth in the area
and the fact that it is a large presence
in Ludlow's folklore the natives of the
town knew that the creature wronged the
lands and in the film it's said that
they tried to keep all from entering the
area that it inhabits by building a
large wall that is difficult to scale we
were screed the main protagonist of the
film their never encountering the
creature directly almost comes face to
face with it in the woods when tracking
to the ancient burial grounds and it's
definitely evident that something wrongs
the area so why exactly does it do this
well in pet cemetery the Wendigo roams
the land in order to control all life
there that dies after it has become
deceased the Wendigo has the ability to
reanimate bodies and send them back to
the living
unfortunately reanimation by the Wendigo
causes psychosis and the corruption of
the soul and this is why those brought
back in the film ultimately end up
attempting to harm and kill those around
them the Wendigo is said to have placed
a curse on the land in pet cemetery and
this is why it is able to do this
similar to penny wise in it
the wendigo just wants to harvest the
townfolk and we'll do whatever it can in
order to continue its supply of bodies
to the land the reanimated corpses tend
to live for roughly 10 years and then
die again which is why a constant supply
is needed this is why it lets those
passed through its land and while Luis
is never harmed by the creature when
treading in its territory the Wendigo
knows that one by one Luis will bring
family members up to be reanimated there
and that they will kill upon their
return which will force him to go back
to the land and repeat the cycle
the Wendigo too is said to have the
ability to possess people and due to its
connection to the spirit world it is
able to find intimate details about
those around the host it takes over this
can be seen in the film when Ellie
taunts Jud about the death of his wife
and in the original novelization of the
work Timmy Bateman one of the first
people to come back to life due to the
grounds also taunts those around him the
Wendigo is a master manipulator and
operates from the shadows much like the
place it chooses to hide in the film
it's able to coerce the townfolk
and fill them with doubt guilt and
insecurities as it slowly drives them to
feed its land with more bodies this is
why Victor appears so much in the film
after Luis fails to save him Victor has
no supernatural abilities himself but
the Wendigo is using the death to taunt
Luis and this is why he has visions of
the sacred land before ever even
visiting there so where does the Wendigo
come from exactly well in Native
American culture the Wendigo is a
mythical evil spirit that is a byproduct
of the United States and Canadian
landscape though it takes on the
appearance of a monster it is - able to
appear in human form though eventually
if this is prolonged the person appears
more and more monstrous as time goes on
historically the Wendigo is associated
with our animalistic side and it
represents giving in to our deepest and
darkest desires with things like murder
greed and culturally taboo behaviors
whilst the creature is predominantly
dealt with in legend in real life there
is also such a thing known as Wendigo
psychosis this is a medical diagnosis
for people in indigenous communities
taking on a craving to eat flesh so how
else does the Wendigo play into kings
well along with Pet Sematary the wendigo
has also featured in the girl who loved
Tom Gordon in that a girl named Trish
McFarland becomes separated from her
family when hiking with them and after
becoming lost has several breakdowns the
Wendigos stalks her with the intent to
take her as its next victim throughout
the woods it leaves warning signs and
omens that lead her dancer in paths
before eventually appearing as people
from her life in order to quarter the
Wendigo appears as the prophet of God of
the Lost and states that all who resists
the Wendigo are met with death which
helps it to persuade Trish as she falls
deeper into the forest
eventually Trish makes it out of the
woods but the Wendigo appears as a bear
and attacks her luckily she is saved by
hunters who shoot at the creature and it
retreats to the forest to wait for more
victims whilst it hasn't reappeared in
King's work since it's safe to say that
it's never too far away and I can
definitely see this boot being adapted
due to the success of Pet Sematary
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the Wendigo and Pet Sematary if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and leave your thoughts on the movie in
the comments below if you'd like a more
in-depth breakdown a pet cemetery then
make sure you check out my ending
explained analysis of the film which
would be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]